الا يشكل فوز الرئيس التركي ارزوان صفعه
كبرى لكل الذين كانوا يراهنون على سقوطه
الا يسارعون الان لراس الصدع مع انقره بعد
ان اصبحت بيضه القبان بين شرق والغرب اليس
متوقعا لها مستقبل مشرق بعد ان عاد حزب
العداله والتنميه الى الساحه التركيه
والدوليه اقوى من قبل لكن في المقابل الم
يترافق فوز اردووان معا انهيار على كل
الاصعده في الداخل التركي وتوتر كبير مع
الغرب الا يشكل انهيار العمله التركيه
والتضخم وتراجع الاقتصاد التركي تحديا
كبيرا للرئيس التركي وحكومته ماذا يمكن
للقياده التركيه ان تفعل اكثر مما فعلت
[موسيقى]
تركيا الى اين بعد هذه الانتخابات التي
شغلت العالم اجمع من مشهد الاحتفال
العالمي العربي الاسلامي من حجم التبريكات
والتهنئات التي وصلت لرايس تركي رجب طيب
اردوغان منذ زعماء العالم نستطيع ان نجيب
وان ندرك اين هي تركيا الان التحديات
كبيره وخطيره على الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تحديات داخليه تحديات خارجيه ان
نحافظ على قوه تركيا ان نحافظ على القمه
التي وصلنا اليها وسنكون اقوى في المرحله
المقبله على العكس على الاطلاق اعتقد ان
تركيا مقبله على تحول كبير في المشهد خلال
الفتره القادمه تركيا امام مفترق خطير
وكبير لجهد تداعيات وما افرزته نتائج
الجولات الانتخابيه الاولى والثانيه نحن
اليوم امام انقسام كبير وعميق في المجتمع
التركي ليس ككل الانقسامات هذا الانقسام
خطير قاعدته الاساسيه الايديولوجيا الانقس
بين تيار معارض تيار علماني ممثل بيك
الجدار اوبلو حصل على الاصوات نصف الشعب
وبين تيار ديني اقرب للاصوليه لن يستطيعوا
ان تكون هناك قدره على صياغه الحلول لسبب
بسيط لان التحديات اكبر بكثير على عكس
الانقسامات الديمقراطيه الموجوده في
المجتمعات الغربيه والدول الغربيه
الانقسام داخل تركيا ذو منحه ديني روحي
فلهذا هو اخطر من غيره كيف ترد المقدمه
التي تفضل بها ان تركيا الى الانهيارات
وان تركيا الى الفشل بعد هذه الانتخابات
نفس الكلام ذكره في مقاله له في تموز عام
2016 بعد ان افشلنا وكسرنا اقدام وايدي
الانقلابيين هذه المقاله للضيف الكريم في
جريده راي اليوم وبالتالي هل حصل هل
انهارت تركيا هل تراجعت تركيا كلا
وبالتالي كلام ضيفك الكريم مع كل الاحترام
لم اي ان كلامه الان في هذه المقدمه لن
يتحقق لماذا لا نقول ان هذه الفرحه
العارمه اذا صح التعبير او الضجه الكبيره
في الشارع العربي مردها الى ان العرب
باتوا يتوقون الى الديمقراطيه يريدون
زعيما وطنيا يعني ماذا فعل اردوغان
للقضايا الاسلاميه العادله ماذا قدم
اردوغان للقضيه الفلسطينيه يعني بالذاكره
نعود قليلا عندما انسحب من مؤتمر دافوس
واسس هذه الهمروجه وهذه الشعبيه في العام
الماضي من استقبل الرئيس اردوغان استقبل
الرئيس الاسرائيلي ووقع معه اتفاقيات
اقتصاديه كبيره واكد على متانه العلاقات
هذا هذا تاكيد على ان شعبنا عاطفي يعني
مثلا الان عندما يعود الى مصر عندما يعود
الى سوريا انت نعود الى الخليج الا ترى ان
هناك نوعا من تصحيح كل الاخطاء من يطرح
هذا الامر غير دقيق حلو تلك الانظمه فشلت
باسقاط اردوغان تامرت عليه اعلاميا وم
2018 وحاول اسقاط الليره التركيه تاملوا
عليه عسكريا بالانقلاب يدعمون تنظيم بيكا
كافي لماذا لا نقول ان ثبات الموقف التركي
وصلابه الموقف التركي الاردني تحديدا هو
الذي جعل الاخرين يعيدون النظر في مواقفهم
وتصرفاتهم هذا الكلام غير صحيح السؤال
الكبير من الذي يلهث للانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي اليس الرئيس التركي ويفاوضون منذ
العام 2005 على الانضمام الى اوروبا تقول
انهم لماذا يعني يباركون فوز الرئيس
التركي يا سيدي اردوغان يملك ورقه كبيره
هي ورقه اللاجئين هذا الاستثمار في ورقه
اللاجئين من الذي صدع رؤوسنا عبر السنوات
الماضيه بنظريه المهاجرين والانصار اليس
الرئيس التركي اين اصبحت هذه النظريه في
سله المهملات قضيه الاتحاد الاوروبي ربما
ضيفك الكريم يعني ما زال في عشرينيات او
في قبل عشرين سنه هذه الجمله مقبوله اما
الان يا سيدي يا حبيبي نحن نمنع السويد من
شخصيا اردوغان القوي المنتصر المعتز بدينه
يمنع السويد من الدخول الى الناتو لسببين
السبب الاول دعم السويد للتنظيم الارهابي
بكاكاو والسبب الثاني تطاول الثنيد على
القران الكريم وعلى الشعائر الاسلاميه
فيما يتعلق بالمهاجرين رؤسار ما زالت
قائمه واردوغان دفع ثمن هذه القضيه
بالانتخابات تراجع التصويت له بانه يدافع
عن المهاجرين لان هناك جزء من العنصريين
في تركيا
ماذا حصل لليره التركيه بعد فوز اردوغان
هبطت هبطت الليره التركيه مقابل الدولار
مقابل اليورو ومقابل كذا اليس في ذلك مؤشر
على اين تتجه الامور الان بعد فوز اردوغان
عاده يا دكتور فيصل النجاح واستقرار سياسي
في تركيا الان استقرار سياسي الرئيس
والبرلمان من نفس التوجه السياسي استقرار
عاده عندما يحصل استقرار يتحسن الاقتصاد
والعمله العمله يعني في اي بلد لماذا
تراجعت العمله احدث حد ث العكس لماذا يشير
الى ان هناك حرب على الليره التركيه
التراجع الليره التركيه ليس معيارا
للاقتصاد التركي انه يتراجع لان الاقتصاد
التركي ينمو تركيا سوف تبقى في الدور
الاقليمي وسقفها هي
التعامل مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومع روسيا